okay today's topic apparently there's
some clips that have resurfaced of Will
and Jada that everyone's been
circulating I happen to see it thought
it was interesting so I'll play it for
y'all and you guys let me know what
y'all think you know stair perel is
coming to the table she's going to be at
the red table
would you say she has been instrumental
in you and I redefining our relationship
I would say Don't just start filming me
without asking me oh my goodness
there come help us again please
I'm still dealing with foolishness
yeah because she don't just would you
say that she helped us heal the hurts
that we caused between one another my
social media presence is my bread and
butter okay
so you can't just use me for social
media and not you know don't just start
bro I'm standing in my house
don't just start rolling
please watch a stare at the red table
because she's helped us a lot can't you
tell
something interesting about watching
somebody so deeply uncomfortable it
almost looked like he was acting in a
movie if this is all like a psyop or
like some kind of whole acting gig it's
really well done it's well done because
he looks like he's in a crazy scene he
looks like seven pounds or a Pursuit of
Happiness where he's about to break down
crime but real life
if he didn't look like one of his acting
jobs
if that's acting give him all the Oscars
yeah give him bring him back I know he's
banned but bring him back you know to
bring him to the show but you can still
give mail it to him hey hey bring him
back give him all the Oscars all the
supporting role uh main actor uh all the
all the give them all the trophies if
that's acting well done sir and this is
funny it has need to watch her and be
like say it say it he's just like don't
feel me I'm I'm in my home myself
it's a really weird dynamic super weird
super weird I'd say toxic but it really
does speak to
you know one thing you don't want to do
too much of is
judge couples or relationships based off
of Snippets that you see here and there
yeah that being said
you show a lot of Snippets
and after a while you got
you got together a whole movie and then
it's not a snippet anymore it's just a
two hour reel that's a lot of Snippets
that's a lot of footage that's a lot of
Snippets I mean if you're auditioning
you only need three minutes to give you
the part two hours because we know where
your career is going that's a lot of
that's a lot of Snippets
I mean you got her saying I didn't even
want to be married or those other stuff
and and having her daughter write a
letter to Tupac I don't know how much it
was real but like even watching the red
table talking the whole like
entanglement thing like you start to
watch and you realize like oh Jada a bit
of a weirdo yeah you know you know what
you know what's you know what Snippets
are what it's like crumbs but sometimes
you have enough crumbs to build the
whole ass cookie you don't have crumbs
no more you have a cookie and yeah the
red table talk the Snippets as you call
it's a whole cookie you can just tell
it's a whole because Jada is in this
man's psyche in a way that is very
uneasy when this man's out here writing
about how he feels like a coward and how
he's like he wanted a family since he
was five and he'd rather die than be
divorced like yeah that looks like
somebody who'd rather die than being
divor course this man's dies and we're
all witnessing him dying and he's not
divorcing yes
till death do his part he's serious
about that [ __ ] oh yeah way more serious
than a lot of us because that could be
me if I tell you to stop feel me and you
keep feeling I'm slapping that [ __ ] out
of your hand I don't like being on
camera like that confusing right because
you guys are watching me but I only do
it through this lens people are trying
to invite me to do a bunch of this stuff
I say no because I'm controlling this
life I don't like when people be out
here just filming like that and my
partner was doing it when I'm in the
comfort of my own home like no I don't
be doing that [ __ ] if I ask you to stop
and you don't stop like what does that
say about you that I'm deeply
uncomfortable and you don't give a [ __ ]
you still want to record me that's weird
right can we all agree
you're deeply uncomfortable with what
your partner is doing to you you say
stop they're like no nah I got more
questions answer it
a little unease isn't it
um task [ __ ] up
yeah man will looks broken that's a
whole last message will for everything
we've seen from the Oscar him again band
for 10 years all this other stuff like
just his behavior and how erratic a lot
of his and then Jada put out some
release like I don't need him to defend
me she was talking about I don't know I
didn't see that one that was so much to
watch at some point I'm like Ugh it's
like you try to defend Jada but Jada's
not gonna defend you God damn
ah bam not matching your energy let me
see this it's not too often that a
sponsor comes to me I love their product
and I'm excited to recommend it to you
guys today's sponsor raycon earbuds I
decided to play with them for a few
weeks I was so surprised by these that
I'm going to use them full time the gels
these earbuds the gels on them they do
not budge you stick them in here they're
not falling out the sound quality is
fantastic now I'm not going to show you
a close-up of this one because it legit
has earwax for me haven't used it so
much but I love these things they offer
eight hours of play time and 32 hours of
battery life and considering the price
point and how they're set at half the
price of their competitors I'm
unbelievably impressed with these
raycons and if you don't believe me go
check out the reviews with over 48 000 5
Star reviews there's a reason why people
are saying this and having tried it I
agree if you use our promo code you get
15 off so click on the link in the
description below or go to buy
raycon.com and get fifteen percent off
your raycon purchase that's on me people
do not understand
take that back
these past years well we've been facing
a lot of things uh in this Society with
you know the metoo movement and stuff
like that and man don't understand the
word no you know
um no means no
no means no
no means no I agree
but it's crazy that you don't understand
no either when we don't want to talk to
you anymore or we don't want to talk
right now y'all don't understand that
some of y'all not everybody of course
not all women right now he's saying hey
don't feel me
he's clearly uncomfortable with that
you know when you don't hear a clear no
it's not a yes
that's what that is right there you
should ask me
before you film me like that
oh my God I'm dealing with the
foolishness dismissed
dismissed
right away
who cares
ask the question like nothing happened
hey can you come help us I'm dealing
with some foolishness he's been you know
whatever the hell he's the the
belittling is real
go back to my main thing y'all ladies
need to learn what no means as well
when we don't want to talk when we don't
want to talk right now when we don't
want to do certain things you need to
understand that
but y'all keep on going
because what you feeling is more
important than what they feeling you
know when we talk about it's a society
thing that's what it is
not just men y'all too y'all got some
work to do a lot of y'all got some work
to do the entitlement is there and it's
real and if we can see that video is
because
she posted it all the videos are in in
my phone that are not out there because
I didn't post them
she posted it the whole entire thing I
don't know if it's lack of
self-awareness
I total disregard I don't know what it
is I don't know what it is you feel like
it's gendered no man do that too but
it's not highlighted that women do that
as well do what not understanding no I
don't think it's gendered I don't think
it's just women but it's not highlighted
that woman there's not an accountability
on a woman in the past year we've been
putting down on men and it's good that
we do that because there is an
accountability that has to be done but
you have to understand and be yourself
suffer effect on what y'all doing no I I
don't know if it's gendered I've seen
some man do that disregard some certain
things and stuff like that I've seen
that
I've seen that transgendered that's not
what I'm trying to say I'm trying to say
girls women look at your behavior as
well there's some work to be done there
too
look within because in the past year it
was easy to point that man and be like
yo y'all do this y'all do that concur
y'all need to self-reflect and see what
y'all doing what the behavior that
you're doing it doesn't remove that man
or doing this and that and whatever in
the third we've been through that
already we know and when we can
highlight that they're still doing that
that's fine
but you have to self-fulfect on what
you're doing as well but yeah overall I
just think we just watched the undoing
of somebody people have been surfacing
old clips of him making bald jokes about
people oh yeah no no when you do some
[ __ ] like that
they're gonna rummage yo they're gonna
go they went through your trash they
said oh [ __ ] what are these used
condoms uh you and your wife are trying
to go for a child who you been [ __ ]
they're gonna be they're gonna rummage
through the the the dirt
they looks and crannies they found a
clip of him saying you know violence is
never the end so I want to answer
everything with love and compassion and
understanding and then they put the slap
there and then they got Jada saying oh I
don't mind people making jokes about my
ball head I heard everything I'm good
with it and like well why didn't you
tell Will like people are going yeah
yeah yeah
that you you thought it was bad before
yeah yeah you thought it was bad before
the two past years and the three past
years you thought that was bad it's
about to really be bad I'm not gonna go
in front if I see Will on the streets
with his wife I'd be like uh Baldy
I'ma just take a little shot
I'm gonna give him a big old hug you're
gonna give him a hug bro you need to
talk no cause I want to solve everything
with love good luck into the security to
get a hook in
I can get a boat again you can't get a
hugging
true I get a Baldi in for sure true
your ball [ __ ] I could definitely say
that from a distance yeah true yeah good
luck in the hugging I can't you're gonna
get slapped by somebody else I might get
slapped by somebody else but you know
they remember you know what happens what
probably
I just wanna hug I thought did uh sir
your client said that he wanted to solve
anything with love did he get beat like
I mean you know I mean I'm not gonna do
that but it feels bad it feels bad
because I've when I was growing up like
like you said in the other video you
know he was watching freshman
I was watching fresh press too that's
how I learned English I was watching
that religiously after school right
religiously when I went to school with
my teacher Shout Out Mr John keys he
introduced us to that I don't even need
I even think that was possible and I was
looking up to that dude they was a
definition of fresh of what the cool was
and he resembled my cool cousins from
New York and I was like yo it's like
it's like I see them yeah in him right
right every time they came out with a
movie it didn't matter what it was yeah
it was Boys
Independence Day
Men In Black came out I watched
Independence Day I was like King Kong
ain't got nothing on me right I'm like
that's one of the greatest lines from
the movie so for me big no that's that's
that's Training Day
wrong movie you sure
I know welcome to hurt [ __ ] bam that's
independence day yeah when he slaps the
alien in the things
you couldn't afford a real costume so
they just had the tentacles coming out
the [ __ ] hole and they said oh yeah
yeah he slapped an alien yeah yeah and
King Kong ain't got [ __ ] on me that's
Denson Washington okay whatever you know
whatever the same black actors wow
you're being hella white right now yeah
that look the same you know Whoopi
Goldberg preach same Denzel is the one
that uh got eaten by shark right
no that was LL Cool J
yeah
he actually escaped the shark did he
yeah first black guy in a horror movie
that that that that survived I'm not
gonna lie when I see a horror movie and
there's water involving like [ __ ] is
all done and he's swimming in that movie
She swam too yeah and guess what he is
what he's the cook
it's like that's why that's where the
hood comes from it's like I was just
like yo it's it's hard to see someone
that broken that broken down and that
yeah yeah that's just [ __ ] up and I
have to ask also like for all the people
like oh my God it's so beautiful that
will defended Jada it's like do you guys
not feel like she's been throwing him on
the bus for this long and that she's
been harming him no nobody will there be
like the red table talks and all that
infidelity and like that stuff or this
or all this stuff maybe maybe we don't
know maybe it is more even but I mean
just from a perception standpoint it
seems like she's about more damage to
him then that you know what I mean than
anybody else so the whole protecting
thing I find it fascinating but we don't
know what goes on there man so yeah I
don't want to read too much into it
maybe you guys have a different take let
us know what you guys think
put it there will